thank you for taking the time today
thank you this is the uh this is the
last interview of the day this is going
to be the best one
after all that i hope so yeah okay and i
love this album so much it feels
incredibly personal in the final song be
right now you talk about discovering
need to be present in your life so what
was the moment in your life that made
you realize you needed to slow down and
be really here for
today i lost one of my best mates and he
he died and uh
yeah no but i but but it's this is part
of life but i had never lost a friend
and
what happened is like
i just started looking at every day as
my last and i was like well should i
really be doing that today like
shouldn't i be
taking my daughter for a walk and going
around the garden and picking
blueberries or something like that you
know it's uh yeah i think um
it's all about living in the moment now
and tomorrow is not promised
no absolutely i mean
when you when you look at life and even
you look at your lyrics on the album
i've grown up and i'm a father now you
talk about that
and the song that is about the
incredible change that happens when you
become a parent
um for me that change was instantaneous
i remember i had a glass of gin in my
hand and the test came and my husband
and i were like what our lives just
exploded right put the gin down did it
take you a while to adjust
yeah because i started sort of mourning
for my 20s i started being like
oh my god this is the end like i'm not
going to be able to have nights out
anymore and blah blah blah
but the day it shifted was about three
months before lyra was born
i
um
actually it wasn't even me that it was a
friend that said do you really want to
be blasted when your wife uh your wife's
water breaks and i was like no i want to
i want to be able to drive into the
hospital so i sort of calm down stuff
there and you know re the realization
that
you can still enjoy yourself a lot when
you're a parent it's just you pick and
choose your moments like i am not out
every single night of the week but once
a month i'll go out with the boys
and we'll have a great time
yeah because there's nothing like having
a hangover and a baby waking you up
first thing in the morning that is not a
fun time right yeah you know i wouldn't
i i
i don't think i've ever really done that
yet like there's i i cause i my favorite
part of the day is the morning i love
getting up with laura i love making a
breakfast we put on a vinyl we listen to
it so i'll um
i never really get too
messed up anymore and it's always like
red really nice red wine and then before
bed i'll down a pint of water and then
and then go to bed but yeah i mean
don't get me wrong if i'm um
something you know i'm i'm in paris
tomorrow and i'm on my own i'll probably
go out and get pretty can because i'm
not really doing anything the next day
but like i just
when i'm home i don't i don't want to
have that moment where you're hung over
and you're like i don't want to get up
you know no for sure
um i feel like all of this really is a
cause for change it happens so fast and
we have those parenting fails have you
ever experienced that moment where you
were like oh no what have i done
um with your with your daughter
yeah of course of course already yeah
dude there's so many so many things i
mean like
even i don't know i'm sure this is a
very common dad thing but in the like i
took care of all the diapers to begin
with and the like second diaper i put on
was back to front you know like stuff
like that just just stuff
is you you do you just learn from it
because you don't know that you don't
know
how to be a parent i read all the dad
books beforehand and the only actual
good bit of advice that was in the book
was too hot is bad too cold not as bad
this is true that is very good
and don't and don't leave stuff in the
cop make sure they lie flat and that's
it
also good also good for sure
um as part of it as this album is
there's themes of insecurity of
self-worth in the songs like the joker
and the queen when you're feeling down
what do you do to bring a smile back to
your face
uh
i don't know really i don't know because
i like i find it very difficult to get
out of the lows sometimes i feel um
i think it's very difficult to be
sad around my daughter because she's so
smiley and happy so that's always a good
tonic i think to it
um again not to go back to my friend too
many times but when he passed away
like
you have moments where you're super
upset and then suddenly she's just there
and she's like i don't know you're sad
like hey and then you just have to not
not be sad so um yeah i mean she's a
great tonic for for everything yeah
children really are you're right there
can be things going on in your life at
work
anywhere and the moment they bust
through the door it's all about them and
you have to be there
but but but it's almost the the
selfishness that's in a kid's mind
actually is selflessness because it's
making you actually forget the troubles
so actually it's a really mutually
beneficial thing no you're absolutely
right um so many songs or these songs
are
you know love songs to your life your
wife your beautiful child and i know
that your wife actually helped you pick
some songs in the album
in fact she picked bad habits to be the
first single when you're playing songs
for her before the rest of us all hear
them is she basically sobbing in the
corner
no
no she has quite a like
uh
business-minded head about it i think
because she just is like well this is
what i like and i'm kind of like cool
because i don't want her to go this is
what i think people will like she just
goes i like this and i like this and i
think it uh
i mean she hasn't been wrong so far she
hasn't been wrong there's a there's one
song she told me to cut from the album
and now it's off the album it the album
makes more sense she was basically
listening to the album as a whole and
the album's theme is basically like
turning 30 getting married fatherhood
losing a friend and there was this one
album that was just it was a big pop
song and it was it was fun but she was
like i think this sticks out like a sore
thumb
and then i took it off and i'm like oh
wow now this album actually makes sense
yeah it's it's yeah it's good she's
brilliant
she just knows me she just knows me she
likes she's a fan of my music which is
good but she's known me since i was like
11 and she knows what i'm about and i
think she's steered the album into
uh good waters
i love that so does any of this any of
the songs ever get her really emotional
though
like
yeah oddly um
uh okay so there's one song called
collide that that made her cry because
there's a line in it say we drank your
father's whiskey when your grandma died
because that's actually literally what
what what happened um but weirdly i've
written a christmas song with elton john
and it is the most upbeat sleigh bell
hey christmas song in it and it makes it
makes um makes jerry cry because there's
a line in it uh
it goes um
hey guys uh so so kiss me under the
mistletoe pour out the wine let's toast
and pray for december snow i know
there's been pain this year but it's
time to let it go because next year you
never know but for now merry christmas
and it's that long that gets her there's
been pain this year but it's time to let
it go because i think we've had you know
like the rest of the world
we've had like real sadness and loss and
so many people have lost loved ones this
this year and um
you know
it's uh
christmas is definitely a time for
families to get together but it's a time
to reflect on who isn't here and how
much we love them basically no
absolutely um you told us that you still
send music to friends in the industry
like taylor swift so what song on the
album got the best reaction from taylor
she hasn't heard the whole thing to be
fair because i haven't i haven't seen
her she's been she's been overseas for
for a bit um
but yeah i think um
[Music]
i wouldn't know i wouldn't she's
probably heard like four or five of them
but um
yeah i wouldn't know i wouldn't know i
i'd have to ask her but she hasn't she
hasn't heard the entire in in entire
things i really i didn't want to just i
didn't want to send it to her i wanted
to sit down and actually play it because
that's how
we would usually do it you know oh nice
okay um i really love the song
first time you talk about remembering
all your firsts so i want to know
um what do you remember about winning
your first grammy
uh quite interesting you say that
because it's actually the the most um
surreal um
spooky story i played in 2015 i played
with stevie wonder at
uh his songs in the key of life tour uh
um and i played past time paradise
with him and then afterwards he invited
me to his dressing room and we sat
together and he was talking about
thinking out loud and he said
man that song that song really deserved
song of the year at the grammys and i
was like oh it's actually never been
nominated he was like that song will win
song of the year next year at the
grammys and i was like okay
and then i'm at the grammys and i'm
waiting for thinking allowed to be read
out and the person that walks on stage
to present it is stevie wonder and when
he got so he had his braille um
uh
envelope
and he went like that no you couldn't
see who it was and he just went i told
you it i told you
and dude
it literally he saw the future he
literally went this is happening and it
happened it freaked me out
you